And Allah says in the
Quran in surah bakar chapter number two
verse number
156 Allah says
that for the believers whenever there is
any calamity they
say to him we belong and to him we
return. Just a few days
ago there was a person who called me and
said
shake my father has been admitted into
hospital. He had heart attack. So I
said rajun he said shake my father
hasn't
died. I said yes I know. Why did you say
that? I said brother in a Muslim ummah
they feel if someone dies we say this
from him we come and to whom we belong.
When anyone dies we
say yes we can say that but for any
calamity one of the calamity is death
okay but even if someone is sick and you
say that so many people think okay do
you want me to die I say no no no I'm
praying to Allah so this is a
misconception amongst some of the
Muslims or many of the Muslims I would
say so this dua that from him we come
from Allah we come to Allah we belong
and to him we return. It's a dua that
any calamity suppose electricity goes
off in the mosque or something happens
the AC goes off any calamity small or
big you can say this
dua so this is a verse of the Quran and
our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said it's mentioned in Sai
Muslim volume number 7 had number
7500 in which the prophet
said
that for a true believer
He's always says alhamdulillah. When any
good thing happens, he says
alhamdulillah and thanks Allah. When any
calamity befalls, he yet says
alhamdulillah. He has faith in what
happened is good and he says
alhamdulillah. This state of a
believer can only be for a
muslim. Imagine you're going in loss and
you're saying alhamdulillah.
You know some people I meet how are you
brother it could have been
better
for how can a Muslim say that could have
been better you know these are
statements from western world you pick
up and you think you're smart how are
you it could have been better these are
statements made by western world you
pick it up it loses your iman you say
alhamdulillah if there is a loss
alhamdulillah only 20% loss maybe I
would have lost 50%. You say
alhamdulillah when prophet is
alhamdulillah when lost this is only a
state of a
believer and a beloved prophet wasallam
said it's hadith of bkari 6258 where the
beloved prophet
said that if I was given a mountain of
gold as big as mount o I would
distribute it in less than 3 days except
take a little bit to pay off my debt.
Because the richest people in Akara
would be the poorest one except those
who spend in the way of Allah and they
are very
few. Make note of this
hadith that the richest people in the
Akar would be the poorest people except
for a
few those who spend in the way of Allah
subhana wa t'ala and they are very few.
wealth the Quran says is a fitna. Fitna
means
test. So when you get rich don't be
happy. When you are
rich your test is more difficult. If you
pass you get higher reward. Therefore
even the sabas who are
richd may Allah be pleased with him
before entering Jenna will be questioned
because he was rich.
Therefore I tell to all the rich people
Allah has given you immense wealth then
make Allah your partner in
business and when you make Allah your
partner you cannot make him a small
partner correct make him at least 51%
partner so whatever you earn at least
give 51% in charity then you are
safe generally the Islamic ruling is
that if you have wealth more than the
nab level you have to give 2.5% this is
fur for every rich person who is not a
fak who's not a fuk who's not poor yes
give 2.5% that is the sharia but if
you're extremely
rich this is my suggestion it's not part
of the sharia it's my advice that if you
want to be safe Allah has made you a
millionaire other people
earning maybe few hundred a month you
are earning $50,000 a month $100,000 a
month what do you You make Allah your
partner. Even if you give more than 50%
yet you'll be multiple times richer than
the poor
man. When my son started business two
years back I said my son when you start
business minimum 51% you give to Allah
subhanaa tala minimum. I'm a veteran so
I give more afterwards maybe you can
maybe compete with me or catch up with
me.
minimum. The more you get, the more you
receive. So wealth is a fitna. Allah
says in surah taba chapter 9 verse
number 34 and 35 that those who hold
wealth and spend it not in the way of
Allah, Allah will in the hellfire and
akar will brand you on your forehead, on
your flanks and on your back and Allah
will say have the taste of the wealth
you hold it. What is money? And
unfortunately for many of the Muslim
money is the most important.